hola bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24 en español en esta oportunidad
nos acompañe a julio césar bufano ex
sacerdote y autor del libro conocerme me
hizo libre en ese libro cuenta su
experiencia siendo homosexual y
sacerdote en la iglesia católica julio
césar bono muchísimas gracias
es un placer tenerlo en france 24
muchísimas gracias y un saludo para toda
américa latina y también gracias por
bueno la repercusión que está teniendo
este libro que más allá de que es un
libro autobiográfico que es una opción
de la editorial planeta de también
cuestionarse desde ese lugar es un libro
que lo que viene a decir que
normalicemos lo injusto que normalicemos
que hace a niños niñas y adolescentes
que siguen siendo víctimas de abuso
sexual que haya personas que vivan en
condiciones infrahumanas y que haya
discriminación a las mujeres a la
diversidad porque en realidad lo natural
es la diversidad y ese sería el el dios
en el que yo creo y en el qué muchas
iglesias cristianas se apoyarían un
libro julio absolutamente recomendable y
de lectura necesaria diría yo julio en
su libro señala algo que llama la
atención hoy es que la iglesia católica
ha sido un lugar de refugio no para
jóvenes gays un destino donde se liberan
por ejemplo de presiones sociales como
por ejemplo tener novia casarse tener
hijos es un lugar de condena hostil pero
a la vez permite vivir a muchos su
sexualidad julio
si sabes es parte de la incoherencia o
de la hipocresía que yo voy contando yo
lo que hago es contar mi proceso lo que
me pasó a mí desde que me descubrí
homosexual y ya estaba era religioso y
que pasaba con ese sentimiento de sentir
algo que dicen que dios condena que la
iglesia condena al mismo tiempo cuando
te están diciendo que la vocación
sacerdotal como algo tan sagrado es que
fuiste elegido por dios entonces qué
pasa con eso dios equivocó yo me
equivoco la iglesia se equivoca entonces
bueno voy contando todo mi proceso de mi
salida del armario del closet como
decimos todas las personas tenemos
distintos armarios pero también las
hipocresías que hay hay todo un sistema
perverso que atraviesa las muchas de
estas civiles de las de las iglesias a
mí me gusta hablar de las iglesias
incluso dentro de la iglesia católica
porque hay diversidad de corrientes y
opiniones en todos lados y gente que se
la juega y que hace cosas muy buenas
pero también hay muchas cosas que se
ocultan que se niegan y
y también se puede hacer muchos años en
nombre de ese dios que te eligió para
hacer curas se puede hacer el bien pero
también se puede hacer mucho daño como
se ha hecho y se sigue haciendo en
muchos casos en julio ahora de lo que
fue su paso su estadía en romano usted
dedica gran parte de su libro a toda esa
etapa cuando llegó a roma se encontró
por decirlo de alguna manera con una
suerte de epicentro católico no del
mundo gay en el libro dice que roma fue
la excusa y también la oportunidad para
poder comenzar a tener la vida de un
cura gay qué sucedía así en roma' que le
abrió todo ese nuevo mundo y cómo se
sintió al encontrar esa realidad
bueno primero me sentí como liberado
para poder vivir la homosexualidad con
total tranquilidad
vivir una vida también este
de alguna forma incoherente con lo que
predicábamos y eso fue lo que empezó a
cuestionar y no quería yo para mi vida
los presos por eso yo digo que es un
libro sobre los procesos que fui
haciendo yo los encuentros y
desencuentros con mi propia consciencia
mis hipocresías también por las tipo que
decía que vi y viví en la institución en
el vaticano especialmente la facilidad
para tener relaciones sexuales y a mí no
me importa si los curas o las religiosas
tienen o no relaciones sexuales mientras
sean entre adultos en todo el tema del
celibato me parece que es un tema a
revisar y lo que voy diciendo es la vida
hipócrita que se vive es condenar a la
homosexualidad porque generalmente la
obsesión es con la homosexualidad es
porque en la diversidad en general de la
boca para afuera pero después vivirla
tranquilamente
y en muchos de los ámbitos sobre todo en
los ámbitos de los varones ya las
mujeres en general las religiosas en
general están mucho más reprimidas y
tienen mucho menos derechos y también en
una institución tan tan machista como es
la iglesia católica pero ahora en su
libro no ven conocerme me hizo libre
cuenta que en roma' del sexo era moneda
corriente que a partir de esos vínculos
se podía incluso ascender y que los
curas homosexuales eran más homofóbicos
que la minoría heterosexual donde
encuentra usted el germen la raíz de esa
doble moral
bueno es parte del sistema perverso este
que tiene una cultura de la dominación
que se desarrolló en varias iglesias
cristianas pero especialmente en la
iglesia católica el nombre de un dios
único padre macho heterosexual no
entonces
si te dicen que eso es una construcción
cultural por supuesto porque jesucristo
en que yo creo estaría en la marcha de
la diversidad y estaría apoyando a las
personas con los derechos más vulnerados
entonces por supuesto que la iglesia
católica si vos ves las estadísticas y
los estudios y otras investigaciones y
yo doy un montón de datos que hay de
otros autores incluso de la academia la
mayoría de los curas que dejan los ex
curas son heterosexuales los gays siguen
adentro bueno hay muchísimos elementos
que que se van dando por distintos
motivos que yo explico e intento
explicarme el libro que acá en pocos
minutos es difícil que tiene que ver
también con esa con ese invento del
vaticano que es la expresión ideología
de género que es un invento del vaticano
después de 1995 cuando la conferencia de
la onu en beijing le da todos los
derechos a las mujeres el vaticano como
estrategia empieza a hablar de ideología
de género como un adoctrinamiento de
género y una colonización ideológica y
en américa latina sabemos muy bien que
la iglesia católica
en colonizar entonces acá lo que tenemos
que hacer son de construcciones
culturales con cuestionamientos
hay algunas teologías que lo hacen hay
algunas personas dentro de la historia
que se anima a hacer como actualmente
recientemente nada más y nada menos y
por primera vez en la historia una a
subir un cardenal cardenal marc en
múnich se atrevió a publicar un
documento oculto desde la época de
el papa juan 23 donde se habla de la
obediencia de vida que era que en el
caso de los abusos sexuales que es un
tema que me importa mucho porque yo
cuento en mi libro que yo fui víctima de
abuso sexual y soy un sobreviviente
porque eso me parece que iba a ser
importante para mucha gente y sobre todo
para varones que es algo de lo que no se
habla mucho ya debería escandalizarnos
los datos que ha hecho las mujeres pero
sobre varones nos habla mucho y ha
tenido un gran impacto tengo muchísima
gente que me escribe para contarme su
experiencia para poder sanar para
transformarse en sobrevivientes bueno
nada más y nada menos que el cardenal
marc de múnich publicó recientemente
un informe de más de 2.000 páginas donde
aparece aparece esto de la obediencia de
vida que era del papa juan 23 donde se
decía que en los casos de abuso de
pedraza se debía negar se debía ocultar
y se debía llamar a silencio y si no se
silenciaba eso si estaba prohibido
hablar del tema y eso de alguna forma
sigue pendiente y sigue vinculado en la
cultura de la iglesia católica que es
muy difícil o más difícil de cambiar en
una organización es la cultura y eso
sigue pasando se siga ocultando se sigue
tapando y por eso me parece importante
que haya habido ahora un cardenal que
deja que expone muchísimo a ratzinger
sobre todo pero a toda la iglesia y que
prácticamente haya quedado en
visibilizado y ha se ha quedado solo
como suelen hacer cuando hay algunas
voces que salen a hablar de determinados
temas como en el caso de mi libro que
plantea muchos de estos temas de alguna
forma a la sociedad no le gusta mucho
esto y se agarran con el mensajero al
mensajero como dijimos después no hay
que pensar sobre los mensajes hay que
deconstruir y hay que pensar si sos
creciente en el dios o en la diosa que
sea o en el jesús el que yo creo que
jesús estaría sin lugar a dudas siempre
del lado de las víctimas niños niñas y
adolescentes que siguen sufriendo abusos
sexuales y esa debería ser el escándalo
eso debería escandalizarnos en todos
nuestros países y no tanto si un cura se
acuesta o no con otro varón o con una
mujer o con quien sea mientras sean
adultos y por qué cree julio que la
iglesia se transformó en este lugar de
abusos sistemáticos a menores
bueno yo creo que los
que esta cultura de la dominación de
imponer una supremacía que es en el
fondo imponer machismo moralismo miedo
culpa discriminación a las mujeres y a
las diversidades a la disidencia es como
un caldo de cultivo perfecto para
ocultar muchas de estos crímenes porque
son criminales no porque francisco el
vapor francisco dijeron hay que
perdonarlo e importarlos con el perdón
no es suficiente porque hay una
concepción antropológica que el cuerpo
es lo malo y por lo tanto si yo pido
perdón es un pecado y me pueden perdonar
esa concepción la tenía comparto el
segundo muy fuerte y por eso hamás
expulsó o prácticamente no expulsó a
ninguno de los curas obispos o
cardinales abusadores y es un lugar es
muy muy propicio porque tenés un poder
muy grande tienes acceso a los niños ya
las niñas
tienes acceso a través de la confesión
por ejemplo y poder reconocer una
cantidad de debilidad es
vulnerabilidades que de otra manera
sería muy difícil y también es muy
difícil para la comunidad creer que el
cura o el pastor o tu representante de
dios pueda llegar a ser un abusador y
por eso es tan difícil este tema por eso
es difícil denunciar por eso yo digo que
los héroes y heroínas que se animan si
están animando a hacer las denuncias no
la denuncia dentro de la institución
electrónica la denuncia en la justicia
civil o penal es así donde hay que hacer
las denuncias porque la iglesia católica
sigue con su derecho canónico y sus
justicias paralelas y en muchos casos
niegan y revictimizan y ya es muy
difícil para las personas en sus cuentos
mi caso a mí me llevo más de 20 años
poder hablar de que fui víctima de abuso
y de violación pues bien es un tema ya
muy difícil que lleva muchísimo tiempo
ahora están saliendo también gracias a
la prensa gracias a investigaciones y
gracias a gente que se la juega como en
este caso un cardenal pero también es
muchísima gente dentro de las iglesias
que no quiere
esta iglesia que oculta que niega y
minimiza que quiere una iglesia con un
jesús que se la jugaría siempre por las
personas con los derechos más vulnerados
y estaría del lado de las víctimas sobre
eso no le pongo duda como el jesús que
se enoja con mercaderes del templo
cuando yo creo que se nos haría mucho
con los obispos y los cardenales que
siguen y los superiores religiosos que
siguen ocultando que siguen negando y
trasladando a los curas o minimizando en
temas que es un delito en realidad no
julio césar lo fueron muchísimas gracias
por este tiempo en france 24
gracias a ustedes y bueno el libro lo
pueden encontrar en la editorial planeta
conocerme me hizo libre y se trata de
eso de ser libres porque la verdad sólo
la verdad nos hará vivir absolutamente
muchísimas gracias una vez más a julio a
nuestra audiencia como siempre le
invitamos a seguir informándose en el
resto de nuestra programación y también
en france24 punto com sigan con nosotros
[Música]